منذ اليوم الأول الذي بدأنا فيه
المواعدة ، كنا نتحدث عن الأطفال
عندما اكتشفت جوسلين رودريغيز وزوجها
أنها حامل ،
ولم يتوقع الزوجان أبدًا أن شيئًا ما قد يكون خطأ ،
ولم يكن أحد منا يعرف حقًا ما هو السنسنة
المشقوقة
حتى تم تشخيص إصابتنا به
أكدت الموجات فوق الصوتية في 18 أسبوعًا أن
رودريغيز قالت إنها قيل لها إن الجراحة
قبل ولادة الطفل
يمكن أن تساعد ، لكن هذا إجراء معقد ،
هذا العيب هو عيب حقيقي
إذا كان الطفل
الذي أجريناه في
مستشفى ويني بالمر للنساء والأطفال في أورلاندو هيلث
هناك تقنية جديدة  ساعد
جراح أعصاب الأطفال الدكتور سمر البابا في
استخدام نموذج ثلاثي الأبعاد لجنين رودريغيز
للمساعدة في تخطيط الجراحة
لتكون قادرًا على رؤية حجم
وموقع الخلل
من النموذج الحقيقي إلى الحياة المطبوع من
صورة التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي ،
هذه التكنولوجيا تجعل
الجراحة
أكثر أمانًا وأكثر إفادة
للآباء قبل
الجراحة ويساعدني كجراح في إجراء
الجراحة
باعتبارها آمنة أكثر وأكثر فعالية و
q
إنها مستحقة في نهاية يونيو لكن
رودريغيز تقول إنهم
رأوا بالفعل تحسينات في
الموجات فوق الصوتية لقد كانت
ترفس أصابع قدمها وتحرك كاحليها
وهي تحب أن تعاني من الفواق ، أعني أن
كل
ما كنا نتمناه قد
حدث بالتأكيد الآن.  أتمنى
أن يحملوا
ابنتهم بين ذراعيهم للدقيقة الصحية أنا
ماندي جيثر